[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en el espacio porque
científicos del consorcio telescopio de
sucesos compuesto por 11 telescopios
gigantes ubicados en diversas partes de
la tierra lograron tomar la primera foto
del agujero negro sagitario a estrella
que se encuentra en el centro de la vía
láctea con su nave hasta ahora no
teníamos una imagen que confirmara que
es agitar yo a estrella es un agujero
negro a blanco
hoy el telescopio horizonte de sucesos
está encantado de compartirles la
primera imagen directa de este gigante
en el centro de nuestra galaxia del
centro barrial xxi la imagen del
consorcio muestra puntualmente una parte
central oscura que es el agujero que
absorbe todo lo que se le acerque
incluida la luz a su alrededor se ve
justamente un anillo de luz generado por
los gases calientes que por el
sobrecalentamiento emiten radiación
esta es una colaboración internacional
con cientos de científicos alrededor del
mundo y es internacional porque los
telescopios están situados en diferentes
naciones hay uno en españa' otros en sur
américa norteamérica y también en el
polo sur así que grandes equipos se
reunieron para recolectar los datos y
procesarlos
y analizar todo fue muy difícil en el
caso de este agujero negro en particular
porque su radiación es bastante débil
wic es casi como tomar una foto de un
objetivo que se mueve no estaba
obteniendo mucha luz del rey
recordamos que un agujero negro se forma
cuando una estrella con una gran masa
llega al final de su vida con una
explosión conocida como supernova este
agujero negro tiene 4 millones de veces
la masa de nuestro sol su diámetro es de
60 millones de kilómetros y se encuentra
tan lejos de la tierra que no representa
un peligro de hecho se estima que
probablemente nuestro planeta ya haya
desaparecido antes de que pueda ser
absorbido por sagitario la estrella
y la analogía que se hace a menudo y es
realmente encantadora es que el centro
de la galaxia es como un centro urbano
todo es más extremo está abarrotado las
cosas se mueven rápido casi todos los
escritores la fuerza del campo magnético
los vientos de las estrellas es un
entorno caótico
es una región astrofísica extrema y muy
concurrida sabes la analogía similar es
que vivimos en los suburbios las cosas
están tranquilas aquí
cambiamos de tema pero continuamos fuera
de la tierra puntualmente en marte donde
el robot per se viven centrada en la
segunda fase de su misión el explorador
a marte hizo en febrero de 2021 y en su
primera etapa realizó tareas de
reconocimiento de los alrededores del
cráter g0 mediante un minihelicóptero
ahora empezará la segunda fase que puede
parecer bastante lenta y consiste en
prepararse para enviar a la tierra las
muestras de roca que ha recogido
a medida que exploramos el cráter g0
recolectamos pequeñas muestras del
tamaño de un bolígrafo
de los núcleos de las rocas allí para
que pueda mostrar los de vuelta a la
tierra para verificar si hay o no signos
de vida antigua en estas rocas
nos encantaría ser todo allí mismo con
él perseverance que fuera el explorador
el que encontrara los signos de vida
pero sabemos que para hacerlo preciso y
seguro necesitamos analizar estas rocas
aquí en la tierra lo que haré en cada
recorrido del robot identificamos una
roca que creemos realmente interesante
nos detenemos la miramos de cerca la
perforamos y guardamos ese núcleo dentro
del explorador cuando está tan perforado
y seleccionado todas las muestras que
deberán regresar el equipo enviará a
otro pequeño robot a recogerlas ese
robot las colocará en un pequeño cohete
que se pondrá en órbita a su vez el
cohete se encontrará con un satélite que
finalmente lo devolverá a la tierra
cuando hablamos de un proceso lento se
debe a que las primeras muestras
estarían volviendo a nuestro planeta
para 2030
finalizamos en portugal donde una
experiencia inmersiva permite que los
visitantes vivan lo que sintieron los
residentes de la capital portuguesa en
1755 cuando se registró el sismo que
devastó a lisboa y dejó más de 40.000
fallecidos
de un recurso inmersivo no es un viaje
inmersivo que nos lleva al pasado
manejamos con todo el rigor científico
histórico transportar a la gente dentro
de esta vivencia conseguimos colocar
estos dentro de una historia para ese
momento no existían las mediciones ni
los instrumentos adecuados para
determinar la magnitud de los hechos no
obstante se estima que este terremoto
sería equivalente a 8,5 grados de
magnitud y se cree que ha sido el más
intenso que se ha registrado en el
continente europeo así que yo así como
media parte creo que yo como todos los
residentes de lisboa vivimos con esta
idea de que esto puede volver a pasar un
día nos preocupa y nos asustan estos
tubos y energía lidad produce en
realidad portugal está en una área de
riesgo pero no tiembla tan seguido como
en países como japón o tres de ellos
como nos llaman por ejemplo así que no
es una preocupación diaria
es uno de los objetivos del centro es
que los visitantes se vayan con un poco
más de conciencia al respecto y de cómo
se deben preparar para el intento 7 que
un clímax q siento que post es diferente
pérez aun después de la experiencia
inmersiva los visitantes pueden
dirigirse a una sala de capacitación
donde puedan aprender más sobre el
terremoto de 1755 las principales fallas
de la región y justamente las
características más importantes que
tienen la mayoría de los terremotos
así llegamos al final de este espacio
les agradecemos su sintonía y los
invitamos a continuar con nosotros en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]